Miley Cyrus and Liam Hemsworth are  finally flaunting their love again  the actors and rumored fiance stepped  out for their first joint appearance  since rekindling their romance earlier  this year and the two lovers looked  adorable at variety's power of women  luncheon in LA friday to celebrate the  singers cover story we're so excited  miley ward this flirty floral ensemble  turning heads in a navy and white  pantsuit with a polka dot pattern while  Liam who showed up to support his lady  look sharp in a black tux the pair ran  into actress Helen Mirren and stopped to  pose for a cute pic the cute duo was  also spotted snapping silly selfies  during the ceremony and at one point  even packing on the PDA for a sweet  snuggle unlike the luckiest ever  you